Los avances que han tenido lugar en la astronomía,
cosmología y biología, en los últimos diez años,
son realmente extraordinarios --
hasta el punto en que sabemos más de nuestro universo y de cómo funciona
de lo que muchos de ustedes se imaginan.
Pero hay algo más que he notado
mientras esos cambios ocurrían, mientras las personas se daban cuenta de
hmm ... sí, realmente hay un agujero negro en el centro de cada galaxia.
Los escritores de ciencia y editores -- No debería decir escritores de ciencia,
debería decir personas que escriben acerca de la ciencia
-- y editores que se sientan alrededor de unas cervezas
después de un duro día de trabajo y hablan de
algunas de esas percepciones increíbles acerca de cómo funciona el universo.
E inevitablemente terminarían en lo que yo pensaba era un lugar muy extraño,
el cual es, formas en las cuales el mundo acabaría repentinamente.
Y de eso quiero hablar hoy, (risas)
Ah, ustedes se ríen, tontos. (risas)
Voz fuera de escena: ¿Podemos terminar más temprano hoy?
(Risas) ¡Sí, necesitamos el tiempo!
Primero, todo me parecía un poco fantástico, pero después de desafiar muchas de estas ideas,
empecé a tomar muchas de ellas seriamente. Entonces ocurrió el 11 de Septiembre,
y pensé, oh, Dios,
no puedo ir a la conferencia TED y hablar acerca de cómo se acabará el mundo.
Nadie quiere escuchar eso. ¡No después de esto!
Esto me llevó a discusiones con otras personas, otros científicos,
acerca de tal vez otros temas, y uno con el que hablé
quien era un neurólogo, dijo,
sabes, pienso que hay muchas soluciones para los problemas que nos mencionaste,
y me recuerda de la charla de ayer de Michael
y su madre diciendo que no puedes tener una solución si no tienes un problema.
Entonces buscamos soluciones para las maneras en que el mundo se podría acabar mañana,
y oh sorpresa, las encontramos.
Lo cual me lleva a una grabación del presidente Bush
en una conferencia de prensa hace unas semanas.
¿Podemos reproducirla, Andrew?
Presidente Bush: "Lo que cueste el defender nuestra seguridad,
y lo que cueste el defender nuestra libertad, debemos pagarlo"
Estoy de acuerdo con el presidente.
El quiere 2 billones (2e12) de dólares para protegernos de los terroristas el próximo año,
un presupuesto de 2 billones (2e12) de dólares que nos llevará a un déficit fiscal muy rápido
-- pero los terroristas no son la única amenaza que enfrentamos.
Hay muy serias calamidades mirándonos a los ojos
las que negamos de la misma forma
como con los terroristas y lo que pudo pasar el 11 de Septiembre.
Yo propondría, que si tomamos 10 mil millones de dólares
del presupuesto de 2.13 billones (2.13e12) de dólares
-- lo cual es un -- o es 2 centésimas de ese presupuesto
-- y diéramos mil millones de dólares a cada uno de estos problemas
de los que les voy a hablar -- la gran mayoría puede ser resuelta
y podríamos lidiar con el resto. Así que espero que encuentren esto fascinante --
Me fascinan estas cosas, debo admitirlo --
para mi son -- las cucarachas de Richard.
Pero también espero -- porque pienso que la gente en este salón puede literalmente cambiar el mundo
-- espero que se lleven algo de esto con ustedes,
y cuando tengan la oportunidad de ser influyentes,
traten de que se gaste mucho dinero en estas ideas.
Empecemos. Número 10: Perdemos la voluntad de sobrevivir.
Vivimos en una increíble era de [la] medicina moderna;
estamos más sanos que hace 20 años.
La gente alrededor del mundo está recibiendo mejores medicinas --
pero mentalmente, nos estamos desmoronando.
La Organización Mundial de la Salud estima
que una de cada cinco personas en el planeta está deprimida clínicamente.
Y la OMS también dice que la depresión es la
epidemia más grande que la humanidad ha enfrentado.
Pronto, los progresos en genética y aún mejor medicina
van a hacer que pensemos que vivir 100 años es algo normal.
Una niña nacida mañana en promedio - la media - vivirá 83 años.
La longevidad de nuestra vida aumenta casi un año por cada año que pasa.
Ahora el problema con todo esto de envejecer
es que la gente mayor de 65 [años] tiende más a suicidarse.
¿Cuáles son las soluciones?
No tenemos seguro de salud mental en este país,
y es -- (Aplauso) -- es realmente un crimen.
Algo como el 98 por ciento de toda la gente con depresión --
y quiero decir depresión severa
-- tengo un amigo con una pasmosa depresión severa
-- la cual es una enfermedad curable, con la medicina actual y la tecnología actual.
Pero es frecuentemente una combinación de terapia hablada y pastillas.
Las pastillas por sí solas no lo remedian, particularmente en gente clínicamente deprimida.
Deberías poder ir a un psiquiatra -- o a un psicólogo --
y asentar tu co-pago de 10 dólares, y obtener tratamiento,
justo como lo haces cuando te cortas el brazo. Es ridículo.
Segundo, las farmacéuticas no van a desarrollar realmente sofisticadas
drogas psicoactivas. Sabemos que la mayoría de las enfermedades mentales tienen
un componente biológico que puede tratarse.
Y sabemos asombrosamente más sobre el cerebro ahora
que hace diez años. Necesitamos un jalón-empujón del gobierno federal,
a través del Instituto Nacional de Salud [NIH] y la Fundación Nacional de Ciencia -- NSF --
y otros como ellos para empezar a ayudar a las farmacéuticas
a desarrollar algunas drogas psicoactivas avanzadas.
Pasando al Número Nueve -- no se rían -- los extraterrestres invaden la Tierra.
Hace 10 años no podrías haber encontrado un astrónomo --
bueno, muy pocos astrónomos -- en el mundo quienes dijeran que
hay planetas en cualquier parte fuera del sistema solar.
En 1995 encontramos tres, y la cuenta llega ahora a 80,
estamos encontrando dos o tres por mes.
Todos los que hemos encontrado, por cierto, están en esta pequeña esquina donde vivimos,
en la Vía Láctea. Debe haber millones de planetas en la Vía Láctea,
y como Carl Sagan insistió por mucho años,
y se rieron de él por ello, debe haber miles y miles de millones en el universo.
En unos años NASA lanzará cuatro o cinco telescopios hacia Júpiter,
donde hay menos polvo, y comenzar a buscar planetas como la Tierra,
los cuales no podemos ver con la tecnología actual, ni detectarlos.
Está siendo obvio que la probabilidad que la vida no exista en otras partes del universo,
y probablemente cerca de nosotros, es una idea remota.
Y la probabilidad que alguna de ella sea más inteligente que la nuestra es también una idea remota.
Recuerden, hemos sido una civilización avanzada --
una civilización industrial, si lo prefieren -- por 200 años,
aun cuando cada vez que voy a Pompeya me asombra que tuvieran
el equivalente de un McDonald's en cada esquina también.
Así que no sé cuánto ha progresado la civilización desde el año 79 A.C.
pero hay una gran probabilidad -- realmente creo esto,
y no creo en los extraterrestres, pero -- y no creo que haya extraterrestres en la Tierra
o algo parecido. Pero creo que hay la probabilidad de que enfrentemos una
civilización más inteligente que la nuestra.
Ahora, ¿qué sucederá? ¿Qué tal que vengan, saben, para
aspirar nuestros océanos por su hidrógeno?
Y batirnos como moscas, en la forma en que batimos moscas cuando entramos
en la selva y comenzamos a talarla.
Podemos mirar nuestra propia historia -- el fallecido físico Gerard O'Neill dijo,
"La civilización occidental avanzada ha tenido un efecto destructivo
en todas las civilizaciones primitivas con las que ha tenido contacto,
aún en los casos donde se hicieron todos los intentos
por proteger y conservar la civilización primitiva."
Si esos extraterrestres vienen a visitar, nosotros somos la civilización primitiva.
Así que ¿cuáles son las soluciones a esto? (Risas) [Gráfica: Hacer que el Departamento de Estado elabore un plan para negociar con civilizaciones avanzadas.]
¡Gracias a Dios que todos podemos leer!
Puede parecer ridículo, pero tenemos una historia bastante mala de anticipar cosas como esta
y estar preparados de hecho para ellas.
¿Cuánta energía y dinero se lleva de hecho tener un plan
para negociar con especies avanzadas?
Segundo, y van a oírme más respecto a esto --
debemos convertirnos en una nación que mire hacia afuera, que surque el espacio.
Tenemos que desarrollar la
idea que la Tierra no durará para siempre,
nuestro sol no durará para siempre --
si queremos que la humanidad dure para siempre tenemos que colonizar la Vía Láctea.
Y eso no es algo que esté más allá de la comprensión en este punto.
(Aplauso)
También nos ayudará mucho si encontramos una civilización avanzada en el camino,
si estamos tratando de ser una civilización avanzada. Número ocho --
Voz fuera de escena: Steve, eso es lo que voy a hacer después de TED. (Risas y Aplausos)
¡Lo tienes! El trabajo es tuyo.
Número ocho. El ecosistema colapsa.
El pasado julio, en "Science" [Ciencia], la revista "Science."
19 oceanógrafos publicaron un muy, muy inusual artículo --
no era realmente un reporte de investigación, era un sermón.
Dijeron, hemos estado observando los océanos desde hace un largo tiempo,
y queremos decirles que no están en problemas, están cercanos al colapso.
Mucho otros ecosistemas en la Tierra están en verdadero, verdadero peligro.
Estamos viviendo una época de extinciones masivas que excede el registro de fósiles
por un factor de 10,000.
Hemos perdido un 25 por ciento de las especies únicas de Hawái en los últimos 20 años,
esperamos que se pierda el 25 por ciento de las especies en California en los próximos 40 años.
En algún lugar de la selva del Amazonas está el árbol marginal.
Cortas ese árbol, y la selva se colapsa como ecosistema.
Realmente hay un árbol así ahí. Esto es verdaderamente a lo que llegamos.
Y cuando ese ecosistema colapse, puede arrastrar un ecosistema mayor con él,
como nuestra atmósfera. Así ¿qué hacemos al respecto? ¿Dónde están las soluciones?
Hay algunos modelos de ecosistemas funcionando ahora.
El problema con los ecosistemas es que los entendemos tan pobremente,
que no sabemos que están en problemas, hasta que es casi demasiado tarde.
Necesitamos saber antes que estén en problemas
y necesitamos ser capaces de inyectar posibles soluciones a los modelos.
Y con la clase de poder de cómputo que tenemos ahora
-- hay, como digo, algo de esto funcionando, pero necesita dinero.
La Fundación Nacional de Ciencia necesita decir -- ya saben,
casi todo el dinero que se gasta en la ciencia en este país
viene del gobierno federal, de una manera o de otra.
Y tienen que priorizar, ¿sabes?
Hay gente en la Fundación Nacional de Ciencia
quienes pueden decir esta es la cosa más importante.
Esta es una de las cosas sobre las que debemos pensar.
Segundo, necesitamos crear amplias reservas de biodiversidad en el planeta,
y comenzar a moverlas.
Hay un experimento en proceso durante los últimos cuatro o cinco años en la ribera del Georges --
o en los Grandes Bancos frente a Newfoundland. Es una zona de no pesca.
No puedes pescar ahí por un radio de 200 millas.
Y una cosa sorprendente ha sucedido - casi todos los peces han regresado,
y se están reproduciendo como locos. Vamos a tener que comenzar a hacer esto
alrededor del globo. Vamos a tener que tener zonas de no-tomar.
Vamos a tener que decir no más tala en el Amazonas por 20 años.
Déjenlo recuperarse, antes de que comencemos a talar otra vez.
(Aplausos)
Número siete. Accidente de acelerador de partículas.
¿Recuerdan ustedes a Ted Kaczynski, el Unabomber?
Una de las cosas sobre las que deliraba era que un experimento en un acelerador de partículas
pudiera salir mal y comenzar una reacción en cadena que destruiría el mundo.
Y muchos físicos de mente sobria, lo crean o no,
han tenido exactamente la misma idea.
Esta primavera, hay un colisionador en Brookhaven, en Long Island --
esta primavera van a hacer un experimento el cual crea agujeros negros.
Están esperando crear pequeños agujeros negros.
Esperan que se evaporen. (Risas)
Espero que tengan razón. (Risas)
Otros experimentos de colisionador -- hay uno que sucederá
en el CERN - el cual tiene la posibilidad de crear algo llamado "strangelets",
los cuales son como antimateria cuando quiera que chocan con otra materia la destruyen,
y la obliteran. La mayoría de los físicos dicen que los aceleradores que tenemos hoy
no son realmente tan poderosos como para crear agujeros negros y strangelets
para que necesitamos preocuparnos, y probablemente estén en lo cierto.
Pero -- alrededor del mundo, en Japón, en Canadá --
hablan al respecto -- de revivir esto en los Estados Unidos.
Cerramos uno que iba a ser grande.
Pero hay charlas de construir aceleradores muy grandes.
¿Qué podemos hacer al respecto? ¿Dónde están las soluciones?
Tenemos al zorro cuidando el gallinero aquí.
Necesitamos -- necesitamos el consejo de físicos de partículas para hablar de física de partículas
y lo que debe hacerse en la física de partículas,
pero necesitamos ideas externas y vigilancia
de lo que pasa con esos experimentos.
Segundo, tenemos un laboratorio natural envolviendo la Tierra.
Tenemos un campo electromagnético envolviendo la Tierra,
y es constantemente bombardeado por partículas de alta energía, como protones.
Y no -- en mi opinión -- no pasamos suficiente tiempo
observando ese laboratorio natural y calculando lo que es seguro hacer en la Tierra.
Número seis: Desastre Biotecnológico.
Es uno de mis favoritos, porque he hecho varias historias acerca del maíz BT.
El maíz BT es un maíz que crea su propio pesticida para matar al barrenador del maíz.
Puede que hayan escuchado de él -- escuchado que le llaman Starling,
especialmente cuando retiraron del mercado todas esas tortillas
hace como un año y medio.
Esta cosa se suponía era únicamente alimento para animales en los EEUU,
y se metió en la cadena alimenticia humana, y alguien debió haber calculado
que se metería en la cadena alimenticia humana muy fácilmente.
Pero la cosa alarmante es que hace un par de meses, en México,
donde el maíz BT y todo el maíz alterado genéticamente es totalmente ilegal,
encontraron genes del maíz BT en plantas silvestres de maíz.
Ahora el maíz se originó, pensamos, en México.
Este es el almacén de biodiversidad genética del maíz.
Esto trae de vuelta un escepticismo que había estado ausente recientemente,
que las súper-yerbas y súper-plagas se podrían difundir alrededor del mundo
originadas en biotecnología, que literalmente podrían destruir la provisión de alimentos del mundo
en muy poco tiempo.
Así, ¿qué hacemos al respecto?
Tratamos a la biotecnología con el mismo escrutinio que aplicamos a las plantas nucleares.
Así de simple. Este es un campo sorprendentemente libre de regulaciones.
Cuando sucedió el desastre Starling, había una batalla entre la
EPA y la FDA sobre quién realmente tenía autoridad, y sobre qué partes de esto,
y no pudieron arreglarlo durante meses. Eso es una locura.
Número cinco, uno de mis favoritos. Reversión del campo magnético de la Tierra.
Lo crean o no, esto sucede cada algunos cientos de miles de años,
y ha sucedido muchas veces en nuestra historia --
el Polo Norte se va al Sur, el Polo Sur se va al Norte, y viceversa.
Pero qué sucede, mientras esto pasa,
es que perdemos nuestro campo magnético alrededor de la Tierra durante un periodo de unos 100 años,
y eso significa que todos esos rayos cósmicos y partículas
van a venir emanando hacia nosotros desde el sol,
y el campo que nos protege, son -- bueno, básicamente nos vamos a freír. (Risas)
Voz fuera de escena: Steve, tengo algunos sombreros adicionales abajo.
Así ¿qué podemos hacer al respecto? Ah, por cierto, ya estamos retrasados --
han transcurrido 780,000 años desde que esto sucedió.
Así -- debió pasar hace unos 480,000 años.
Ah, y aquí hay otra cosa
-- los científicos creen que nuestro campo magnético se ha disminuido un cinco por ciento.
Así que quizá estamos en su agonía.
Uno de los problemas de tratar de calcular qué tan saludable está la Tierra,
es que tenemos -- ya saben, no tenemos buenos datos climáticos de hace 60 años,
mucho menos datos en cosas como la capa de ozono.
Así, hay una solución bastante simple a esto.
Va a haber un montón de cohetería barata disponible,
en unos seis o siete años,
que nos puede llevar a la atmósfera baja muy barato.
Ya saben, podemos hacer ozono en los escapes de los autos.
No es difícil -- es sólo tres átomos de oxígeno.
Si trajeras la capa de ozono completa a la superficie de la Tierra,
tendría el espesor de dos monedas, a 14 libras por pulgada cuadrada.
No necesitamos tanto ahí arriba.
Necesitamos aprender a reparar y reponer la capa de ozono de la Tierra.
(Aplausos)
Número cuatro: Llamaradas solares gigantes.
Las llamaradas solares son enormes expulsiones magnéticas desde el sol
que bombardean la Tierra con partículas subatómicas de alta velocidad.
Hasta ahora la atmósfera ha hecho - y nuestro campo magnético ha hecho --
bastante bien protegiéndonos de esto.
Ocasionalmente, tenemos una llamarada desde el sol que causa estragos
con las comunicaciones y así por el estilo, y la electricidad.
Pero lo alarmante es que los astrónomos recientemente han estado estudiando
estrellas similares a nuestro sol,
y encontraron que un número de ellas, cuando tienen alrededor de la edad de nuestro sol,
se abrillantan por un factor de hasta 20. No dura mucho tiempo.
Y piensan que esas súper-llamaradas, millones de veces más poderosas
que cualquier llamarada que hemos tenido desde nuestro sol hasta ahora.
Obviamente no queremos una de esas. (Risas)
Hay un lado contrario -- estudiando estrellas
similares a nuestro sol hemos encontrado que pasan por periodos de disminución,
cuando la cantidad total de energía que expelen
baja quizá un uno por ciento.
Uno por ciento no suena a mucho, pero podría causar una infernal era del hielo aquí.
Así, ¿qué podemos hacer al respecto?
(Risas) Comenzar a terraformar Marte. Este es uno de mis temas favoritos.
Escribí una historia al respecto en la revista "Life" en 1993.
Esto es ciencia espacial, pero no ciencia espacial difícil.
Todo lo que necesitamos para hacer una atmósfera en Marte,
y hacer un planeta habitable en Marte, está probablemente ahí.
Y sólo tienes que, literalmente, mandar pequeñas fábricas nucleares
que consuman el óxido de hierro en la superficie de Marte y escupan el oxígeno.
El problema es que se toma 300 años terraformar Marte, mínimo.
Realmente más como 500 años para hacerlo bien.
No hay razón por la cual no empezar ahora. (Risas)
Número tres: ¿No es esto interesante?
-- Una nueva epidemia global. La gente ha estado en guerra contra los gérmenes
desde que hay gente,
y de vez en cuando los gérmenes obtienen una victoria.
En 1918, tuvimos una epidemia de gripa en los EEUU que mató a 20 millones de personas.
Eso cuando la población era de unos 100 millones de personas.
La plaga bubónica en Europa, en la Edad Media,
mató uno de cada cuatro Europeos.
El SIDA está regresando, el Ébola parece estar levantando la cabeza
con demasiada frecuencia,
y las viejas enfermedades como el cólera se está volviendo resistentes a los antibióticos.
Hemos aprendido la clase de pánico que puede ocurrir
cuando una vieja enfermedad levanta la cabeza, como el ántrax.
La peor posibilidad es que un germen muy simple, como el estafilococo,
para el cual tenemos un antibiótico que todavía funciona, mute.
Y sabemos que el estafilococo puede hacer cosas sorprendentes.
Un célula de estafilococo junto a una célula muscular en tu cuerpo puede tomar genes de ella
cuando llegan los antibióticos, y cambiar y mutar.
El peligro es que algún germen como el estafilococo será --
mutará en algo que sea realmente virulento, muy contagioso,
y se esparcirá a través de la población antes que podamos hacer algo al respecto.
Ha pasado antes. Hace unos 12,000 años,
hubo una ola masiva de extinciones de mamíferos en las Américas,
y se piensa que pudo ser una enfermedad virulenta.
Así, ¿qué hacemos al respecto?
Es una locura. Le damos antibióticos -- (Aplausos) --
a cada vaca, cada oveja, cada gallina, les dan antibióticos cada día,
todo -- ya saben, va a un restaurante, comes pescado, tengo noticias para ti,
es todo de granja. Ya saben, tienen que preguntar cuando van al restaurante si es pescado silvestre,
porque no te lo dirán. Estamos regalando el código --
esto es como estar en guerra, y darle a alguien tu código secreto.
Le estamos diciendo a los gérmenes cómo luchar contra nosotros.
Tenemos que arreglar eso. Tenemos que hacerlo ilegal de inmediato.
Segundo, nuestro sistema de salud pública, como vimos con el ántrax, es un verdadero desastre.
Tenemos un real brote importante de enfermedad en los EEUU,
y no estamos preparados para enfrentarlo.
Ahora hay dinero en el presupuesto federal, el próximo año,
para reforzar el servicio de salud pública.
Pero no pienso de ninguna manera que eso es realmente lo que se necesita.
Número dos -- mi favorita -- nos encontramos agujero negro salvaje.
Ya saben, hace 10 años -- o hace 15 años, realmente --
si entraras a una conversación de astronomía y dijeras,
"Saben, creo que probablemente hay un agujero negro en el centro de cada galaxia,"
y te sacarían a gritos del escenario.
Y ahora si fueras a una de esas convenciones y dijeras,
"Bueno, no creo que hayan agujeros negros ahí," te sacarían a gritos del escenario.
Nuestra comprensión de la manera en que el universo funciona es realmente --
se ha incrementado increíblemente en los años recientes.
Pensamos que hay unos 10 millones de estrellas muertas sólo en la Vía Láctea -- nuestra galaxia.
Y esas estrellas se han comprimido hasta algo como 12, 15 millas de diámetro, [19-24 km]
y son agujeros negros. Y están tragándose todo a su alrededor,
incluyendo la luz, por lo cual no podemos verlos.
La mayoría debe estar en órbita alrededor de algo.
Pero las galaxias son lugares muy violentos, y las cosas pueden lanzarse fuera de órbita,
también, el espacio es increíblemente vasto.
Así que aun cuando lanzaras un millón de esas cosas fuera de órbita,
la probabilidad que una de ellas de hecho nos golpee es bastante remota.
Pero -- sólo tiene que acercarse, unos mil millones de millas [1.6 mil millones km], una de esas cosas.
Unos mil millones de millas distante [1'600,000,000 km], aquí está lo que le pasa a la órbita de la Tierra --
se convierte en elíptica en lugar de circular.
Y durante tres meses del año,
las temperaturas en la superficie suben a 150 o 180 [grados Fahrenheit; 65-80º C],
por tres meses del año bajan a 50 [grados Fahrenheit; -45º C] bajo cero.
Eso no funciona muy bien. ¿Qué podemos hacer al respecto?
Y esta es mi más espantosa -- (Risas) [Gráfica: Apresuren la búsqueda de otro planeta como la Tierra.]
No tengo una buena respuesta para esta.
Otra vez, tenemos que pensar respecto a ser una raza colonizadora.
Y finalmente, la número uno -- el mayor peligro para la vida como la conocemos, pienso,
un asteroide realmente grande se encamina hacia la Tierra.
La cosa importante de recordar aquí -- no es cuestión de si,
es cuestión de cuándo, y qué tan grande.
En 1908, un -- solamente un fragmento de 200 pies de un cometa --
explotó sobre Siberia y aplanó bosques por quizá cien millas [165 km].
Tuvo el efecto de unas 1,000 bombas de Hiroshima.
Los astrónomos estiman que pequeños asteroides como esos llegan cada 100 años,
en 1989 un asteroide grande pasó a 400,000 millas [643,737 km] de la Tierra.
Nada de que preocuparse, ¿correcto?
Pasó directamente a través de la órbita terrestre. Estábamos en ese lugar seis horas más tarde.
Un asteroide pequeño, digamos de media milla de ancho [800 metros], iniciaría tormentas de fuego
seguidas de un serio enfriamiento global debido a los desechos lanzados hacia arriba --
el asunto del invierno nuclear de Carl Sagan --
un asteroide de cinco millas de ancho [8 km] causaría extinciones mayores --
pensamos que el que extinguió a los dinosaurios era de unas cinco millas [8 km] de ancho.
¿Dónde están? Hay algo llamado el Cinturón de Kuiper,
el cual -- algunas personas piensan que Plutón no es planeta,
ahí es donde está Plutón, en el Cinturón de Kuiper.
También hay algo un poco más distante llamado la Nube de Oort
Hay unas 100,000 bolas de hielo y roca -- cometas, realmente --
ahí afuera, que tienen 50 millas [80 km] de diámetro o más,
y con frecuencia se dan una vuelta
hacia el sol y pasan razonablemente cerca de nosotros.
De mayor cuidado, pienso, son los asteroides que existen entre Marte y Júpiter.
Los tipos del Mapeo Celestial Digital Sloan nos dijeron el otoño pasado --
ellos están haciendo un mapa del universo -- un mapa tridimensional del universo,
que hay probablemente 700,000 asteroides entre Marte y Júpiter
que tienen media milla o más [de diámetro].
Así que dices sí, bueno, ¿cuáles son las probabilidad de que esto ocurra?
Andrew, ¿puedes mostrar la gráfica?
Esta es un cuadro que el Dr. Clark Chapman del Instituto de Investigación del Suroeste
presentó al Congreso hace unos años.
Observarán que la probabilidad de que un impacto de asteroide / cometa te mate
es alrededor de uno en 20,000, de acuerdo al estudio que ellos realizaron.
Ahora miren la línea justo abajo de ella.
Choque de aeroplano de pasajeros, uno en 20,000.
Gastamos una barbaridad de dinero tratando de asegurar que no muramos en accidentes de avión,
y no estamos gastando casi nada en esto. Y sin embargo, esto es completamente previsible.
Finalmente tenemos, justo desde el año pasado, la tecnología para detener esto en seco.
¿Podríamos tener las soluciones?
La NASA está gastando tres millones de dólares al año -- tres millones de verdes --
eso es moneda fraccionaria -- en la búsqueda de asteroides.
Porque de hecho podemos descubrir cada asteroide que esté ahí afuera,
y si puede golpear la Tierra, y cuando puede golpear la Tierra.
Y están tratando de hacer eso.
Pero se tomará diez años, gastando tres millones de dólares al año,
y aun así dicen que habrán catalogado alrededor del 80 por ciento.
Los cometas son un asunto más difícil.
Realmente no tenemos la tecnología para predecir las trayectorias de los cometas,
o cuando uno con nuestro nombre pueda llegar.
Pero tendríamos mucho tiempo, si lo vemos venir.
Realmente necesitamos un observatorio dedicado.
¿Han observado que un montón de cometas son nombrados en honor de gente de la que nunca han oído hablar --
astrónomos aficionados? Esto es porque nadie los está buscando, excepto los aficionados.
Necesitamos un observatorio dedicado a buscar cometas.
La parte dos de las soluciones -- necesitamos averiguar cómo estallar un asteroide,
o alterar su trayectoria. Ahora hace un año, hicimos una cosa asombrosa.
Mandamos una sonda al cinturón de asteroides,
llamada NEAR, Near Earth Asteroid Rendezvous [Encuentro Cercano a la Tierra de Asteroides]
Y estos tipos orbitaron un 30 -- o no, un asteroide de unas 22 millas [35 km] de largo llamado Eris.
Y entonces desde luego, ya saben, salieron con una de esas trampas de la NASA
donde necesitan baterías extra, y combustible extra y todo eso,
y entonces en el último minuto aterrizaron --
cuando la misión terminó de hecho aterrizaron en la cosa.
Hemos aterrizado un cohete en un asteroide. No es gran cosa.
Ahora el problema es que solamente mandar una bomba tras esta cosa,
es que no puedes empujar contra algo en el espacio, porque no hay aire.
Una explosión nuclear es tan caliente,
pero realmente no tenemos algo tan grande como para derretir un asteroide de 22 millas [35 km] de largo.
O vaporizarlo, sería más apropiado.
Pero podemos aprender a aterrizar en esos asteroides que tienen nuestro nombre
y poner algo como un motor de propulsión iónica en ellos,
el cual gentil, lentamente, después de un periodo de tiempo, lo empuje a una trayectoria diferente,
la cual, si hemos calculado correctamente, le impida golpear la Tierra.
Esta es cosa solamente de encontrarlos, ir allá, y hacer algo al respecto.
Se que les da vueltas la cabeza con estas cosas.
¡Caray! ¡Tantas amenazas!
La cosa, creo, es recordar, el 11 de Septiembre.
No queremos que nos tomen desprevenidos otra vez.
Sabemos de estas cosas.
La ciencia tiene el poder de predecir el futuro en muchos casos ahora.
El conocimiento es poder.
Lo peor que podemos hacer es decir, vale, ya tengo bastante de qué preocuparme
sin tener que preocuparme de un asteroide.
Es un error que literalmente nos puede costar nuestro futuro.
Gracias.